the new york times actually came out
with an editorial
from the editorial board saying that
free speech is important
now that's amazing that the times had
the guts to stand up for free speech
because
you know they're the the people
well
what's been happening with the times is
that they've allowed twitter to become
the editorial board twitter has control
over the new york times and the new york
times literally will change papers i
have an essay in politico with with
nadine strassen steve pinker and pamela
pereski on how
um the new york times
retracted and changed uh an editorial by
brett stevens and they did it in a
sneaky way and they lied about it and
they did this out of fear because he
mentioned iq he mentioned iq and jews
and then he went on to say uh it
probably isn't a genetic thing it's
probably culture but he mentioned it
and the new york times i mean they were
really cowardly now i think they from
what i hear they know that they were
cowardly they know that they should not
have fired uh james bennett they know
that they gave in to the mob and that's
why they're now poking their head up
above the parapet and they're saying oh
we think that free speech is important
and then of course they got their heads
blown off because you know twitter
reacted like how dare you say this are
you saying racist speech is okay but
they didn't back down they they didn't
retract it they didn't apologize for
defending free speech
so i think i think the times might be
coming back
you